so nice to get to talk to you
so big fan of oracle 2 your voice is
just so perfect for this uh what can you
tease us about nate russo's journey this
time around
well poor nate he's still having a
pretty rough go of it um
this is not the the light rom-com
version of nate russo so
we we pick up uh
not too far after the end of the the
first novel
and
uh he is back in familiar environs and
still trying to work his way through
this terrible gift that he has
and also try to become some version of a
functioning human being which you know
he is
less often than more
yeah this is true um what can you tease
us about dreamland because this is not
your average fun
amusement park
no well i don't know i feel like
all amusement parks are a little creepy
they are right yeah right there's like a
little sinister-ness to like mine
growing up was the pne
and
part of the part of the joy of those
places is going and scaring the hell out
of yourself it's true right so there's
there's just and then there's just like
when you look back on it as an adult
you're like why did i trust those people
with my life
those ferris wheels did not seem safe no
though like in the old school
roller coasters were definitely not safe
a hundred percent not sick so i don't
know i think there's like a there's
something there's something kind of
sinister to that there's also something
sinister to the
the like on the surface everybody's
happy town you know where everything's
just a little too clean and everybody's
just a little too polite and you're like
i don't know people are not like that
what's really going on here so into that
space steps nate and all of his burdens
and and then the world starts to kind of
explode and peel back and peel back and
go back and andrew has done a great job
again of of telling a story that is
really rooted in
these three central human characters who
are recognizably people right rather
than just archetypes
and then as you go forward in a
progressively more fantastical story
yeah it's uh it's it's so well done and
it's funny because even within like the
first five minutes like you're sucked in
and then the episode ends and you're
like oh i need the next one like it's
it's really cool
good
that's good to hear yeah um what do you
like about doing
uh you know a character in a podcast
like this versus a tv show or a movie
um
well i mean
it's in many ways a lot simpler right
you have
the you know your performance is really
your own you can kind of you can
work on it in real time
and
it's fun to just work in voice it's it's
fun to be given the challenge of
like if you take all of this away yeah
like what is left and how do you tell
the story and how do you
you know how do you think about
characterization when you're only
dealing with
voice so it it was a it was a new
challenge because i'd never done
anything like this before so um i
enjoyed that challenge and also
i've never been able to i've never been
given the opportunity to
to play a like a kind of classic film
noir character which nate very much is
so that was a lot of fun too
it's true so then with how much fun you
have on this can you see there being an
oracle three would you be up for that
absolutely yeah i mean i think one of
the
one i don't know if this was intentional
from the very beginning but one of the
things that andrew has done is create a
world that so long as he can dream up a
good story there's always a new place
for these characters to go so um yeah i
would absolutely come back and do
another one yay that's awesome uh you
were saying uh during your virtual q a
you're at the phase with the
you know at home with your daughter
where you're reading where the wild
things are yeah which is very exciting
how nice is it being able to share those
moments with her
i mean nice is not the world it's just
when i read it so i read where the wild
things are too early and she wasn't
interested and then i read her again
like two
three weeks ago
and
i read the book and she was engaged this
time and then
when
the next day she asked for it by name
that's just like it's just the most
amazing being a father is awesome it's
just oh
i love that so is it everything you
thought or way better oh it's way better
than i ever imagined it's so much more
than i could have conceived of
that's so nice to hear uh do you have a
list of books now now that you know
she's engaged is there like a book
series that you can't wait to get into
with her even if she gets a bit older
i have like we have books for the next
for as long as she'll read with me we
have books for the whole course of her
lifetime
that is amazing
um that sounds awesome so obviously with
et canada we're always covering you know
the latest red carpets and
you and your lady jody turner smith are
just couple goals everyone's obsessed
with you especially i would like to be i
would like to be humble because i am
canadian and it is better for us to be
that way but i cannot be humble we
smashed it at the met gala
she's kind of pretty my wife
she is insanely gorgeous and it's it's
the energy about her too though it's
when she gets on that red carpet it's
like move aside
she glows yeah yeah she definitely does
so does it you also seem like you have a
lot of fun with her on the red carpet is
it fun sharing that those moments with
her
it is very so here's one of the many
wonderful things about my wife those
moments can be very stressful
particularly for women right i know yeah
a bunch of strangers yelling at you
you are literally living out your worst
high school nightmare of like
being judged actively for what you're
wearing
true
so it's a you know there are heightened
moments and she really steps into
the
pardon me potential spam i don't think i
need to get that one but she really
steps into
the joy like she really commits herself
to enjoying that moment and not being
overwhelmed by it and
it is it is fun to be around her in
those spaces
i love that well i can't wait to see
more because you guys just look so
spiffy together it's like honestly like
we freak out we're like oh the couple
has arrived
it's true
that's awesome okay so how would you
describe life right now i mean you have
so many projects on the go give your
daughter you guys are dominating red
carpets like how do you describe life
right now
it's actually quieter than that so
there's a lot of work right now which is
great and
um
uh
you know they're because of because of
covid and the tail end of kovic god
willing but probably not quite the tail
end of kovid
there has been more time to just be home
and be together than there otherwise
would have been in the before times so i
would describe life is very family
oriented right now it's just we have
this little engine of joy who is
so special and and i want to be there
for every moment of it
i love that
so many people are excited for the new
fatal attraction series have you guys
started shooting do you know when that's
going to start
uh we start in the beginning right after
canada day or actually we're in the
states so right after uh fourth of july
[Music]
yeah so we're in the home stretch
getting ready to go
what can you tease us about it or what
are you most excited for especially fans
of the original film to see when it
comes to this series
well
what i'm most excited for in the in the
broad story is that the film
is
is kind of a horror film for men right
right i mean it's like literally your
worst nightmare so what the what our
story does is it allows you to get into
the psychology of the glenn close
character to really understand
the who and the why and the where
uh or where she comes from
and i i think it makes that
that thriller horror element at the
center much scarier
there is a there's an element
there's a moment about uh
halfway through or a third of the way
through the first season
where now as an audience you're kind of
a step ahead of my character of the dan
character so you know what's coming
but any person with sense would be able
to see what's coming and yet he because
of
ego and all the
rest of it
is about to do this very dumb thing yeah
and he does the very dumb thing and
everything goes
and i i don't know that the film is
still i don't know if you've watched it
recently this film is still really
really effective but i feel you know
sexual politics have moved on obviously
quite a lot since 1989. so i feel like
there's a modern there's a an updated
modernized telling of this story that
actually is more impactful
because it allows her you it because it
allows you to really understand
how she happened like what what it what
her motivations are okay see i love that
because i actually just like a week ago
spoke with glenn close and she's totally
on board for this series but she you
could tell she feels a little bit
protective of the character of alex and
he wants to really like tell her
backstory so that's awesome to hear so
she was at the met ball and i had the
you know i worked with glenn close many
many many years ago and so i had the
opportunity to be like hey i'm doing
this thing and i hope you think it's
cool because i think it's cool and she
was she was totally on board with it but
for for exactly the same thing she's
like i'm really protective it's
important to me
because she's a feminist and and has
always
i think worked from that space of like
telling stories of whole women even if
they're you know psychologically uh
uh broken in some way but in being you
know and telling honest women's stories
and i said yeah no look the the whole
point of this exercise is to give that
character more space and get into her
psychology and her backstory
that's so cool we got to talk to her
about that gala that's awesome yeah yeah
she is cool right she was owning a tune
her pink she had like the whole shawl
like she was great i could not be more
fabulous
you